we're wide open to move it up
we are wide open to moving back
we're wide open to just sitting there
taking a guy that
falls to us obviously you know we can
move up
and you got to know what you're trying
to do and how you're trying to do it
you can try to increase your draft
capital by moving down where you stay
the same and
the
four of the first 35 picks gives you an
opportunity to consider all those
scenarios multiple times
if you're looking for any more proof
that crazy stuff happens in the nfl look
no farther than what we just saw john
gruden coach of the raiders mike mayok
gm the raiders two years ago one guy was
a prominent voice and face on espn's
draft coverage the other was a prominent
voice in face on nfl network's draft
coverage now they're working together to
try to figure out which picks to make
and they've got three of them in the
first round to utilize and peter it is
going to be a fascinating night for
raiders fans also terrifying because the
ultimate objective here and i think this
is why john gruden is feeling the heat
and feeling the pressure you've got to
make people forget about khalil mac and
amari cooper with those draft picks that
you're going to be using on thursday
night
yeah i mean look if if there's one thing
that the raiders know that they want to
do here this is going to be the best
draft position they're going to be in uh
probably for the whole maya gruden
tenure i mean if it if it isn't
then mayak and gruden are failing
miserably
and so this is a year where you know
that okay
we we're okay at wide receiver because
we've worked on that in free agency and
in the off season you know
and it in in trade
but i do think right now when you look
at what's happening in this draft
you know that the raiders have to come
out of here with some elements they have
to come out of here with a
without any question they have to come
out of here with a long-term
idea
of at least two more defensive leaders
on this team
and that is something that i don't think
you can underestimate for what they need
to do in this draft i've got them
getting quinn and williams early you
know with the pick with pick four but
the one thing that you can't tell right
now
if ian rappaport is correct and they
might pull a bombshell move
what actually could that be i don't
think any of us really know but i think
you have to start considering really
major things would it involve a
quarterback would it involve an existing
player from another team would it
involve frank clark
those are the kind of things that are
going to get answered on thursday
yeah that was the report yesterday from
rapaport about why the raiders felt
compelled to secure the room and send
the scouts home they need complete
secrecy because they're apparently
plotting some sort of a surprise i'm
going to tell you my theory in a couple
of minutes about why they felt compelled
to clear the room but as it relates to a
potential surprise you know if connor
murray is there at number four i don't
know that that would be a surprise i
don't think he's going to be there at
number four i think the bigger surprise
with him being there at number four not
the raiders taking him if he's there but
what if there's a a decision to take at
dwayne haskins with the fourth overall
pick rapport mentioned that yesterday as
the possible source of this surprise and
that wouldn't be a shock but look any
quarterback they take it's going to make
us say
uh oh
look at what the raiders are doing when
they have derek carr under contract but
we've already seen
enough and heard enough from mike mayok
to come to the conclusion that they
won't be bashful about doing it if they
think
that murray or haskins or someone else
is an upgrade over car mayhawk was
incredibly candid about that a couple of
weeks ago at his pre-draft press
conference
admitting that they looked at these guys
because you have an obligation peter to
always potentially upgrade any position
including quarterback
and i mean you almost would have to
think at the beginning
if you're going to think about taking a
quarterback there
do you have a landing spot for derek
carr
would miami take derek carr
for one or more than one picks
you know could you dissuade the giants
from taking a quarterback
by trading derrick carr there washington
i mean
so those are the things we don't know
right now mike and
and i have always felt that
i won't be utterly shocked if they do
something at quarterback just because at
the combine john gruden was
you know was so uh
you know so in love with uh
kyler murray
so you know we'll see what happens but
that's definitely going to be a place to
watch on thursday night
all right here's my theory on why they
felt compelled to clear the room now
obviously most of the scouts who have
been sent home were going to be fired
anyway because they are reggie mckenzie
guys and now the draft will be over soon
mike mayak and john gruden can fill out
the ranks of the scouts with the people
that they would prefer to have working
for them the whole issue is can they
trust these guys and you made a great
point earlier in the hour about this
need to know basis that most normally
functioning teams would follow which is
the area scouts have no business seeing
the draft board they're not going to see
it my theory is this my theory is john
gruden can't help himself and john
gruden feeling that pressure to
potentially hit a home run three
different times in the first round of
the draft this year and if they do have
some
some curveball they're ready to throw
with the fourth overall pick he's not
going to be able to stop himself from
visiting with the various scouts if they
were in the building this week and
bouncing off of them
his plan for thursday night just because
he wants to sound it out he wants to
talk about it he's impulsive that's kind
of how he is he's fidgety he's nervous
he likes to talk so they're protecting
gruden from gruden by telling all these
guys stay out this week and the only
people in the building that gruden can
talk to are the people who already know
what the plan is what do you think of my
theory
not bad i it might be true
uh i you know i just i don't know i'd be
guessing
and my guess would be that even if they
didn't have a deep dark secret
uh that mayak would be totally paranoid
about somebody leaking
the fact that wow they like cleveland
farrell over dexter lawrence you know if
that if that got in one draft column
mike mayok would know that he's got a
leaker in the room and
you know i what i heard after this mike
is that they already feel that at least
one piece
of pretty confidential information
was already leaked
so
they wanted to
seal it off completely and so we'll see
what happens but
i i'm not i i
i like your theory i have no idea
whether it's true i think it's i think
it's possible
i would guess that it's just that
mike thinks that that area down lower in
the first round particularly is an area
that he wants to protect with all his
might
and you know it is amazing peter just to
get back to what you said earlier how
bill belichick runs his organization and
how most normally functioning teams
would run their organization the area
scouts wouldn't know anything they
wouldn't be in a position to have
confidential information that would be
leaked
it would be restricted to the people who
only need to know as you said need to
know basis top to bottom that's how you
organize it there's a military component
to it where you wall off people
internally who you may you know you
don't want to even get to the point
where you trust them or not trust them
because you never give them information
that they'd have to be trustworthy with
you seal them off without sending them
home that's what makes this so stunning
because i'm sure the raiders are hardly
the first team to be worried about area
scouts knowing things that they
shouldn't know and telling things they
shouldn't tell there are ways to keep
those people from knowing things without
saying go go go take the week off the
biggest week of the scouting year go
home and do nothing
you know when the patriots
you know when when the uh
when the patriots basically prepare for
a draft and are in the draft and the the
scouts are in another room and the
coaches are in another room remember the
year they drafted rossai dowling the
cornerback from virginia
it was either late one or early two i
forget and he ended up being injury
riddled his whole career he never really
was a factor anywhere in the nfl
well that was the year that i think
everybody in the outside world thought
that jabal sheared or brooks reed was
going to be the pick you know a couple
of defensive linemen who had the you
know had the ability to to rush the
passer
and uh and when when rossei dowling
was picked
i was told that so many of the scouts in
the room just
like not threw their hands in the air
but like
that was an utter absolute shock nobody
saw that coming and that is why
you don't let anybody in the room i'm
not i i'm not saying that the pic was
good bad or whatever it obviously turned
out to be lousy but
that's the kind of reason that's the
reason why you don't allow other people
to under to know exactly what you're
doing with your business you don't want
to give that away
let me take it one step farther than we
have to take a break i may have
mentioned this recently
in 2005 nick saban's first year with the
miami dolphins he told people in the
building with the second overall pick he
was taking receiver braylon edwards he
deliberately lied to people in the
building and they ended up taking
running back ronnie brown instead so
that not only can you wall people off
you can spread false information to the
extent that people
can't
honor the the uh the commitment to keep
their mouths shut if they do talk to
somebody they're going to give the wrong
information to the people that they may
be talking to in the media
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports